so let's talk about Adam 22 he's all in
the news with the do you think that that
was a net L For Adam 22 or do you buy
what he says that it was great for his
wife's career as well as his career I
mean certainly got a lot of uh I mean
it's definitely I believe it's
definitely great for their careers I
mean to each their own you know if like
if he's cool with
it is there a such thing as bad
press uh
yes is that bad press I it's not a
cancelable
offense but like I mean even if it's
negative towards Adam or whatever
letting his Lena [__] another dude but
like is it is it bad for business or is
it good for business no it's definitely
good for business because I guarantee
their plug Talk podcast is just and once
she releases that video if she hasn't
already it's going to blow the [__] up
yeah him explaining the [__] Mac what he
did was hilarious yeah you guys keep
bringing up crib Mack who's that 5 dud K
Mack is a guy who's on he's like a no
jumper kind of like side character yeah
yeah and he's this dude and he just like
he hosts a show he's like a legitimate
[__] right okay and he's just really
funny he's just really a character which
is kind of what on a roller coaster was
the best thing I've ever seen he's just
super funny like now I've heard that uh
like the the no jumper like kind of
people have been defecting and leaving
no jumper and doing their own thing and
that it bodess poorly for for the no
jumper brand I I like Adam 22 yeah what
was the vibe when you did the uh the
podast great it was great I um we did a
double upload yep um it was it was
really interesting too because I was
like yeah you know you got your um
YouTube uh Creator Studio Creator studio
app dashboard and it's just like shows
you all of your numbers your last 10
videos how they rank and I just
screenshotted like screw it what do I
care you know let I'll let him see all
of our analytics and uh right away he
sent me his and um at the time our
podcasts were were really pretty on par
with each other wow I think that um like
the the lowend and the highend of
typical views for one of us started
lower and went higher but it was the
range was very similar and I thought man
how cool you know yeah um it it also
helped us I think to um you know I think
double uploads just generally help if
you've got like super super fans they
they want to hear both and you drive
traffic to each other MH I had a great
experience with them nice but yeah with
him and his his chick doing porn now
with other because they've done porn for
a long time just the two of them or like
other chicks would come the plug Talk
podcast is a podcast where they would
talk for 45 minutes with another
chick and then after that then they they
have that's got to be the most fast
forwarded 45
minutes in the history
of um now here here's another example
about how somebody gets the short under
the stick and it's probably not a nice
thing to say but um I I've seen their
Instagram where they show all their
their guests on the plug podcast and
there has not been
one guest that was hotter than his wife
100% of the time they have like Angela
White on they did have Angela White Mia
something Sky Bri I mean I've only seen
hotter chicks no no no dude don't ask me
how I know have all these yeah I don't
know that many porn stars by name like I
don't think I can name 10 I'm stoked
that when uh when we just saw the the
guy who who hammered Vinnie's
girlfriend
Jes I uh I didn't even recogniz I don't
recognize anybody in porn anymore it's
been so long since I swore off it's like
people talking about Molly and you're
like I never even like I missed that
whole boat yeah it was just yeah it was
not Molly there's a lot of things that I
missed and thank god um fenel I yeah
it's going to be out of the mix on
something you can bring up any guest
that's been on plug talk and I submit
that not one of them would be hotter
than Leena the plug well okay who's the
guy that had sex with Lena is he hotter
than Adam 22 ah um I
mean it it's a different he types in the
plug
BBC well you just got to turn off safe
search go over to the right what safe
search safe search is like if you search
it's not going to show you now now safe
search is off now it's not going to
block all safe search on [__] no whose
computer is that definitely not Vinnie's
there we go
okay that's the biggest dick I've ever
seen your
life so he's not like necessarily a
handsome guy but he looks like he'd beat
Adam guy got a
hammer I mean is that even enjoyable for
women at that point like you wash the
porn no I I don't think it's out yet
this is more porn than I've was in years
I yeah we should change maybe we should
turn safe search back on yeah uh I and
we should also be careful about uh using
the word porn and the you know like do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and steo
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude